welcome to the second episode of our
monkey's bum gambage where we are going
to look what happens if your opponent
does not accept our dangerous Gambit
Pawn
well as you already know the opening
mode
ifo G6 Bishop C4 Bishop G7
Queen F3 E6 and after our default if you
look at the database by far the most top
choices are not to accept this pawn and
declined it with these three choices
so let's see each by Tone and find out
how white can still spice up the game
and get some good opening advantages
the first move I want to consider is
least accurate namely C6 so black is
planning to play D5 and accordingly
white should continue with if I put a
breakdown on this clan and here it
doesn't matter whether your opponent
continued with D6 or D5 both can be
equally treated with capture on D6 and
White's big idea is after Queen captures
D6 he wants to play Knight to E2 not
only consolidating his deepawn but as
you can see I have highlighted by the
simple arrows white has a very effective
plan of campaign where the big problem
in the black Camp is his light Square
Bishop is in a complete prison and
altogether this gives white a good
advantage in the opening stage
the second move I want to consider is
Knight to C6
but I think again this is slight
inaccuracy by black and the reason is
very simple now white can defend the
d-pawn with C3
getting this wonderful Center and please
note black cannot play D5 so what he can
do is play Knight G2 E7 and prepare this
idea
where exactly at this point if you look
at the Database Top choices are e-file
Bishop G5 which personally I don't like
it and that's why I'm going to introduce
my own novelty in this line and that
goes with Bishop to D3
allowing black to play the move D5 but
after our E5 it is white we get all
sorts of fun and here the planning is
very simple what we want to do is go
into S3 put the bishop on F6 exchange
this dark Square bishop and then Castle
on the queen side where we can become
hair loose on the king side with the
pawn roller
so this is a very straightforward idea
and black is finding a very difficult
time to play against it
for example the Top Choice in the
database is Castle on the kings of it
we can play Queen to S3
and now if the black doesn't do anything
we can simply continue with Bishop F6
Knight F3 Knight G5 and then mating
attack on the king side
so black has to blast open the center
with absecs
there is a dubious alternative here
namely Knight to fi but you already know
how to meet this yup G4 dislodging the
Knight so that we can play the move
Bishop to F6 and engine suggests that
black should play Knight F captures D4
but
to be honest I don't believe in this
peace sacrifice as a practical point of
view this is definitely a great
advantage to the watch
so nope Knight captures D4 is right out
of the equation so as Knight to F5 so
more or less black has to play F6 and
take action in the center
but
one thing you have to remember is you
want to keep your Center stable so that
you can concentrate on the flank attack
so the only move which makes sense here
is
obvious enough F4
not allowing black any sort of counter
play
if you're far then we can play G4 and
open up of a g file
so black has to take on E5 but after F
captures E5 yes indeed black has opened
up the Rook file but it is white who
enjoy the attacking Advantage here
for example there is a recent Grand
Master game in this line where black
continued with Knight Wi-Fi
looking for the C5 break
white Place Knight to F3 going forever
plan and after C5 Waters Knight to G5
threatening Checkmate on the at7 square
well black prevent this by playing
outside but after Knight to F3 now comes
another problem that you have the S6
Pawn hanging and if you play H5 then the
G5 become a juicy soft spot for the
white pieces and don't forget the G6
Pawn also hang in some lines so that is
the reason why in the game black plays
King 2 at 7 defending or at six
but now comes a very strong move
and that is Bishop to G5
where as I have mentioned earlier
what is clearly going for the quick
Castle idea so rightly so black Exchange
in the center with C captures D4 C
captures D4 Knight to C4
but it seems like what is well prepared
against this as he continued with Bishop
takes C4 Pawn takes C4 and Knight to D2
where black is still struggling to find
any counter play
okay black plays Queen to C7 unpinning
the Knight and defending on C4 to whom
white respawn with a very nice move
Castle on the king side
and after Black's obvious response be
far liberating the last piece
and it looks like wow black is back in
the game
but just one move and black is
completely finished I wonder if you can
see it
need more time pause the video and try
it by yourself I am showing you right
now
the killer tactical blowers
Bishop to at six
what a move and after this I think black
is completely losing
s the forcing sequence happen on the
board
Bishop takes at six
Knight to G5
King to G7 and finally white revealed
his trunk by capturing our f8 which
forced black to capture this Rook saw
that in return not only white regained
his peace back but after King to E8 and
the Moon Knight to E4 just look at the
pathetic position of black king
he is hardly going to survive and if you
look at the engine Evolution here it
says black should resigned the game
sooner or later
finally let's look at the Top Choice
from the database namely Knight to E7
so black idea is very simple he wants to
play D5
whereupon I recommend this simple
approach and that start with Knight to
C3
stopping this important break
well if your opponent take on D4 then
after H4 it directly transpose into the
accepted variation
so no if black has decided to decline
the gambling he is going to Castle on
the king side and finally when white
played Knight to E2 defending the d-pawn
black has two choices
well if we continue with moves such as
D5 then I think this is premature
Black's idea is after Pawn takes D5 e
takes D5 Knight takes D5 Knight takes D5
and Bishop caps D5 he wants to play C6
so that whenever Bishop moves he can get
his Pawn back with Bishop captures D4
Knight captures D4 and queen captures D4
which at First Sight looks like wow
black has completely equalized the game
but see yourself
when White Castles not only he obtained
the bishop pair
but also look at the dark square around
the black king
they are severely weak and our dark
Square Bishop can be create some havoc
in the black can
well to illustrate my point once again I
like to show you a model game from the
database where white finish up the black
so quickly from this position
black continues with Bishop to G4
attacking the queen
slide into the G3 Square
and since there is a threat of C3 black
says okay I'll play Bishop to F5 and get
out of any White's attack
well guess what it is now White Stone to
take the charge Bishop to S6
Rook 28 has been played Rook to D1
attacking the queen
maybe black thought that he has no
problem so he take on B2 but afterwards
Queen to C7 now you see the dark side
the F7 Pawn is hanging
black was probably relying on this move
Queen to F6
but what he missed is White's next
killer moon and that is Rook to D6
which by force wins the game on the spot
how let's find out
well black response is almost forced he
has to block with the bishop and now you
take on B7
attacking another room so once again
black response is false he has to move
the Knight to the D7 Square
But Here Comes the simple idea
did you spot it
congratulations if you find this easiest
Queen sacrifice
and after this what else it is wide Who
come out as a complete peace advantage
and in fact win the game very quickly
last but not least probably the most
critical response here is C6 once again
going for the typical T5 idea and
against this I am going to recommend my
own novelty in this line and that start
with this attacking move at home
White's idea is after Black's D5 Bishop
to B3
he wants to rip open the black king side
with the move H5
and accordingly there are two choices
for the black but neither of them are
walking here
for example the natural move in this
position H5 leads to the problem as
white can play now Bishop to G5 and
followed up with castle and G4 which
gives him hell of an attack
so for example there is a game in the
database which goes like this F6
white moves the bishop back and after
Knight to D7 what else this thematic
break G4
which forces Black's hand as after Pawn
takes G4 Queen takes G4
successfully open up the G file and
maybe black thought that F I give him
the enough counter play but see yourself
E4 looks like wow black has done some
great work in the center blocking white
pieces but nope after raj5 the material
doesn't matter as black king looks
absolutely shaky and indeed after Knight
to F6 and pawn text G6
in the long run to be sure black king is
a complete
probably the most accurate Choice here
is to capture on e4
but after this white can simply
recapture with the Knight threatening
Knight to F6 so that if you play the
move F5 then Knight to G5 create some
huge problem on E6 Square
so that's why by far most popular choice
from the database is to play Knight to
F5
attacking on the weak D4 Square
but
you know what who cares for the material
when you have such a dominating position
you go ahead with H5
opening up the black king side and even
this cost upon that is Knight xd4
Knight takes D4 and queen takes D4
we more or less don't care because in
return it is wide who get a really
attacking position
let's see a high profile game from the
database where white continue with
C3 attacking the queen
to E5 pinning down the Nile but white
says Nope sweetie you cannot stay here
so Bishop to F4 and after Queen to B5
stopping white castling what is more
than happy as after Edge captures G6 it
doesn't matter how we were black plays
the game is a complete corner
for example if you take back with the H
Pawn then
yes you can play Knight to D6 or Castle
but I really like the move G phone
completely stopping Queen to H5 and in
our next turn we want to play Queen to
S3 and create a easy mating attack on
the black game
so that's the reason why Edge captures
G6 is a very risky approach
so in the game black plays F captures G6
thinking that I can create some tactical
idea on the f file
but once again just one move kills the
black
and let's see it Knight to D6 superb moo
in his own right not only you are
attacking the queen but the big time
idea is when black plays the move Queen
to C5
why take on C8 and black simply resign
in the view of Bishop takes E6 and The
Rook is a call
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful world of monkeys
bum Gambit
well as I have shown in this video if
your opponent are covered enough to
decline this Gambit then white should
more than happy as resulting positions
gives lot of fun and good tactical ideas
for the white and as I have shown in
this video with some my own novelty
if you follow them closely you will
definitely snatch some good defeats in
your tournament practice
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will see you in my next episode very
soon
buy and take care